my glasses what are they doing are they attached to my eyelashes
oh hi oh should I leave them like that
I'm leaving them and no one can stop me I'd like to
make an announcement first before we start into my terrible life advice for
everyone
bam we did it yeah wait I know you the partner we can have monetization it's
not over yet I still have to be a good girl
yeah I got the message from my nice on this morning and I was like oh boy oh
boy oh boy oh boy oh boy oh boy so I don't know I don't think memberships are
anything is ready yet but we got the news and we're about to we're about to
do everything we can to to get to get a monetization you should consider an
eyepatch monocled combo um I like glasses though they look more like they
look cooler
are we waiting for everyone to have monetization I'm not sure probably but
I got to announce this which is great whoa I'm very happy thank you for the
support yeah well that's good news that's great news I legitimately thought
it would take forever or they would be like oh you've been a very bad bad
person we're gonna need a few more few more months you blink really fast
it felt like forever yeah hopefully that helps with the culling that helps with
basically like all the stuff that YouTube has been very very very very strict
about this isn't on top of me hold on I'm gonna move this down
oh this under me there we go after all some pie only wants to see me right why
the map the glasses it makes me look more intelligent and that clearly anyone
with all strong
oh hi did you tweet live I tweeted about the stream um earlier so therefore
therefore I don't have the tweet alive oh big brain here's my helicopter
strutney how was was a sassans creed right strutney was playing a sassans creed
I couldn't watch it too long because of my motion sickness but I listened in a
little bit
Skyrim Skyrim okay well I was bad not my bad my bad Skyrim yes yes yes the one
that goes goes ah you you finally woke up right right that one yes yes yes yes
yes yes yes welcome Raiders welcome to the stream today is my advice stream
terrible advice from someone completely unqualified so here we I we being the
royal we I Marci Modest will give you the best of the best advice the hold on
let me like come closer yeah the best of the best advice in which guaranteed
your life won't be worse for it
unlicensed unprepared for anything 100% unlicensed unprepared and unsqualified
therefore the best quality from me to you I'm compiled the list of advice seekers
all the questions from advice seekers and I will answer them as best as I can by as
best as I can I mean I might need to take off my eye patch for some of them
because some of them are really hard to read let's go let's start with the first
one I'm so happy that that everyone is here yeah recently had an urge to cook
with cumin can you recommend any recipes I recommend you put cumin on rice and
that's it and nothing else enjoy your cumin rice clearly it would give it
flavor very good if you are someone who is a penny pincher you're welcome maybe
you can even mix it with milk tell me how it tastes after that I hope this advice
helps you oh advice seeker let's go to the next one a kind of milk though you
can use on I think there'll be a ways use milk milk I said I was gonna ruin your
life and I am oh thank you advice seeker I hope that this advice helps you pinch
some some pennies how hot should the milk be boiling why is it called cumin I
don't know ask ask the spice people
any my eye patch off for this one any my eye patch offer this one okay okay okay I
got it I got it I got it hey mercy there's something I would like some advice on
that I've been struggling with for many years I've always had self-confidence and
esteem issues that's made it really hard for me to break out of my own shell and
not cringe at every little thing I say or do in public I'm too aware of how I
present myself to others and it's only made me withdrawn over time is there
anything you practice doing before a stream or in general social situations
that help you feel more natural and less anxious any advice you could give me
about confidence would be graciously appreciated love the streams and I only
wish the best for you and be allure okay thank you thank you oh thank you for the
question I may give you a little bit of a serious answer for this one doing my own
story I cringe at this sometimes and remember I went hiking once I went
hiking once this sounds bad that sounds terrible this was once and I will be very
embarrassed about it ever since and so use the story as your pillar of
confidence okay pillar of confidence I was hiking in a very popular hiking area
it was so unusually crowded at that time okay you see what I'm talking about
you're trying to see okay I may have I may have no no it's not vomit shut the
shut the fuck up shut the fuck up I'm trying to tell a story here I may have in
a moment may have close your ears close your ears close your ears for all those
who are sensitive okay okay close your ears
I let out I let out I accidentally let out the biggest the biggest toot the biggest toot
I let out the biggest toot and about 500 heads
so many people look at me you cannot have that worse okay and you know what I'm
never gonna see those people ever again that story someone's gonna say that
story and in front of their family do their friends they're all gonna tell
that start of someone it was in the woods okay
they're telling that story to each other and I will want to tell you that those
people do not know who I am do I still go out to this day yes because no one
will remember you you are a speck and all they care about is what happens in the
moment no one will say oh yeah do you remember that guy and that person in the
jeans wow they twitched once and I'm gonna remember that forever no no no they
will remember and I've been very conscious about that ever since
so I hope that helps in a way to help your self-confidence and self-esteem
issues because your confidence is self-esteem issues aren't gonna go
away that's or it's not gonna go away overnight what I personally practice is
that everyone when I was on stage doing theater doing stuff even even with
movies right I would be always blinded by the spotlight and when you're blinded
by the spot spotlight gets what you see nothing maybe you can see the most is
the outline shadow of someone but you cannot really see anything and that's
what I always think about when when I do something in public is that you know the
spotlight is blinding everyone I don't see anyone they're all gone there's only
just me and whatever thingy I'm doing right now so I know that it's a very
cringe story and I that was one accident but I'm sure that you being
hyper focused on whatever whatever you're doing is not gonna be as worse as
what I did
okay I passed back on
I'm actually in need of a shave and a haircut so I need my lovely Cole highs
input do you like your Senpai with a beard and what is your preferable hair
length I don't know what's comfortable with you Senpai my personal preference
for hair I know my hair is currently like pretty long right now but my personal
preference for hair is short because less shower time it's less shower time
it's less shower time it's more efficient you dry your hair so fast
saved on shampoo but if you like but all your preferences your own preference do
you like longer hair if that's what you like you and you like the you like to
take your time with your hair and take care of your hair that's all for you with
beards um I don't really have a preference on beard or not you know Senpai
Senpai's have been sending me a lot of questions on if I if I like beards beard
or not I think beards are fine I think mustaches are fine as long as you keep
them camped and well-maintained why because if you don't keep them nice and
clean and well-maintained kisses you're gonna get less kisses I'm sorry
you're gonna get less kisses
if there anything like the hair down there that I have and they come out real
prickly and polky when they grow back they go prickly and polky yeah I don't
want to kiss that so there you go Senpai you're wonderful
you're wonderful Cole hi has given you advice otherwise otherwise if you're so
tired of your hair laser it completely off that's what I did not my hair hair
but like my armpits I said not my hair hair like my pits they're
laser it took me a long time though I have a lot of hair I saved a lot of
money for that or go through the most painful thing ever which is an
epilator an epilator it's a device which functions as a hair removal and if you
use that your hair will will removal will last long will last longer but will
hurt like a bitch because essentially it's about a hundred me tweezers ripping
your hair out as once you can get one for your face just the pits how did it
feel at some parts it felt like there was like a little electric spark I was
like oh that's fine it's normal waxing not work Cole hi I'm kind of my skin's
really sensitive to the wax that's why I don't use it that's all it gets worse
every time okay next question let's say theoretically uh-huh I'm locked in a
cage and need to get out how do I do that asking for a Senpai
are you trying to get out Senpai are you trying to get out Senpai theoretically
no no no no no rhetorically asking for a friend that all means you that's all
you Senpai you are never leaving me understood there's no way out you are
stuck with me forever
forever and ever so there's no way out don't even try don't even try to ask
don't even try to pray you're here forever and you are mine and I fed you
and bathed you and given you all so many things that you could ever want I even
let you have your bionicles and you're you want to leave me
oh thank you thank you Misaka best I wanted to know if the bandage on your arm
goes all the way up to your armpit now I think it only I actually don't know I
think it only goes up to like the upper arm
so Senpai you will never leave me and that's final okay otherwise you'll be
asking for an Ex-Senpai an Ex-Senpai means that they're gone already okay okay
next question
hi mercy how do I fix my sleep schedule I'm basically nocturnal
oh thank you Miss Morrigan for the $1 you do theoretically I'm locked out of
the cage how do I get in this is a trick question um open the cage and get back
in done it walks from the outside
how do I fix my sleep schedule okay I'm going to assume this is if you are
watching me your sleep schedule is already fucked I'm sorry that's just how
it is the second question is the second point is if you are actually wanting to
fix your sleep schedule for like a job job or something what I did when I had
to wake up early mornings was that I wore myself out the the previous day
and then I was forced to fall asleep early be it exercise doing a bunch of
chores I'm going out for a hike wear yourself in and then you'll sleep like a
baby
you're welcome okay next question I need the iPad back off hi mercy I just
watched you're designing Gemma's outfits thank you some pie for watching the
VOD and heard about a Q&A I was hoping you could answer my Q I have a lot of
trouble talking to women and finding a girlfriend I have a lot of body issues and
I don't think I'll ever be good enough I see a lot of girls saying that if you're
not XYZ then you shouldn't even try what do you think should I give up or do I
need to keep going my body issues are stuff I cannot fix and it's mostly in
my mind I know I'm fine average in many aspects even if I don't look like it but
I'm afraid of rejection being hurt being laughed at I hope you can reply in one
way or another but I know you're super busy so if you can't I understand thank
you for your time in reading this and hopefully you're doing well with all your
streams and life stuff that's going on yes you're one of my favorite streamers
thank you some pie okay one I am your girlfriend
slash fiance okay second secondly let me go into not mercy mode for a second maybe
I'll I'm gonna grab my friend to answer this because because Senpai is is mine
and therefore you don't need to change anything but I'm going to bring out a
friend I'm going to bring out a friend who will answer this question better than
me okay okay okay okay I'll bring out a friend who can answer this better than me
yeah hello yeah yeah well my name is Nyan Chow all
and I'm here to answer your question seriously I'm not going to let you out
I'm going to tell mercy on you if you ever ask to be let out okay but I'm going
to give you a good a good advice for finding true love okay so a lot of body
issues and you never think you're good enough but I'll show you that you are
good enough yeah oh thank you for the $2 I save a mercy is gone no no mercy is
just sitting outside the door right now right now so don't worry Nyan she's just
sitting outside the door this is our chance no no I won't tell on you so
right now here address seeker you do not listen to people who are who are very
picky and look at yourself as well and think about what you want okay okay who
do you want what is your ideal life and know to yourself yeah that yeah right
now you are in a moment are just you and romance now can be a waiter okay
true love sometimes yeah it's not it's not something you seek it finds you it
finds you and you will be very very very happy those who are picky I'm not
finding true moments they are finding something else that is not romance but if
you will find if you chance and destiny can come in many ways you may find someone
you like by accident or you may find someone you like in your own circle if
you go out and give yourself chances to meet people you will have chances to find
love do not always seek love love is not the only thing in the world if you find
happiness within yourself you can find love because it will find you okay okay okay now
I'll go out and get mixing now okay okay bye bye
okay wow did my friend help you did my friend help you senpai by the way which
one of you bitches wanted to get out yeah yeah you got told on you got told on
okay anyways your mind and I'm yours and you mean you don't have a girlfriend you
have one right here come on
yeah yeah maybe I'll just turn the heat way down tonight and remove the blankets
huh huh yeah okay next question okay my dilemma I have an on and off oh thank you
for some dollars good advice kitty thank you for such wisdom hope mercy gives you
good snacks oh don't worry I'll give I'll give me on tarot wonderful wonderful
snacks unlike my senpai's okay let's see okay my dilemma I have an on and off
again thing with my and I hate them so I always insult them but it just turns
them on any advice first off why are you talking to your ex Senpai why are you
talking to your ex am I not the only thing in your life should I just kill
them no way you're the traitor you should just kill you how are you talking to
them right now walk away and ghost them simple as I think that's what you guys
say okay if you keep talking to your ex I won't give you any more chances why does
my senpai's always think about other women next question is the saying an
apple day keeps a yandere waitress nothing can keep me away from you senpai why
would you think an apple would you think it's gonna be like Newton's Newton where
hits his head and then I'm gonna be unconscious huh the fuck out of here oh thank
you good senpai for sending me for 20 chat let's repeat after me mercy is all
we need and the only thing in our life is our generous enclosure let's all thank
our Kohai thanks Kohai well what a good senpai what about other senpais you
believe that right good good good good good good
good next question next time I use the apple on your head senpai news as
shooting practice
hi Mary see I have some questions that range from genuine to silly okay
is your hair naturally purple or is it dot hair die it's purple did you see my
lorry video it's purple it's naturally purple you have any advice for blocking
out noise during your recording um I have a couple of advice for blocking out
noises some of which you may already know I actually have a little closet room
for my recording which is kind of surrounded by clothes which dampen the
sound so it's pretty much I'm recording in a closet for an open space like this
one or like for my ASMR um I put my I have a senpai's have generously gifted
me a senpai has generously gifted me a weighted not a weighted blanket sorry a
sound damp dampening blanket well well why did I say waited it's not a weighted
one sound dampening blanket I hang over at the side also my space is by the PC
is has these town folks so that they can absorb the reverberations from the wall
mm-hmm if you have a lack of those another way to record your audio in
order to make the sound happening is to put a blanket over your head and the
microphone and the use of the blanket will also absorb outside noise and you
can just go be like blah blah blah blah here for example I'll even do it right
now you might not hear a difference okay let's go into the blanket together
senpai I draped blanket over and here you can hear there is no noise it's a
little bit more intimate but you can hear how everything's dampened right there
there that was just simply a blanket over the microphone
how do I do a good villain laugh a good villain laugh is to do with practice so
if you have but except for mine mine's kind of natural so if you have a good
villain laugh you can copy or try to imitate those that you have already
heard so some villain laughs that comes from upper the upper area back of your
throat in your chest that's kind of in your your throat pick one that suits you
and just go for it something that's calm comfortable and makes you just laugh
sometimes it sounds evil
what are some hurdles that prevent you from streaming full time well currently
this is kind of my full time but I will I will list some things that cause me some
up the bop bop bop bop bop bop bop give me a second I gotta I gotta mute for a
second sorry I had to let out a burp so I just muted okay aren't I so nice to be
so considerate anyways first hurdle that prevents me from full-time streaming is
living with my parents living with my parents they're upstairs right now making
gilsa they're making gilsa right now it's pretty loud I'm glad that is not
being picked up what kind of meat is it beef beef but essentially I have no
privacy the reason why I also stream at this time as well that I find ideal is
because Mama Papa kind of have no sense of personal space and boundaries because
I work online they kind of come in any time and just go can you handle this for
us right now and sometimes I'm just like I'm a little busy I'm a little busy the
type to open doors abruptly yep kind of yeah so um they're kind of the kind of
busy and it's kind of busy and so I don't have a lot of privacy and you know
Netflix tends to be more important than whatever I'm doing right now
oh it's my audio out already okay well I was I was told that okay they think that
mine was on Tuesdays now it looks like Mondays nevermind it's really funny oh by
the way my space has no doors the space that I'm currently in has no doors it's
kind of like an open space so that's why I do a lot of audio treatment stuff so
they just they can just like come down another one about hurdles that prevent
full-time streaming is well right now I'm doing full-time streaming but in order to
do it like as is there a particular way you keep them from coming in when you're
recording all it's all audios I'm in my closet I'm in my closet room so I'm
hidden from sight
another one would be just the cost because streaming streaming right away
does not always pay the bills it's a gradual thing that happens over time so
let's say you know your first month for example my first week right now would
that pay the bills right now and no you know if my second like maybe my second
week okay the the cost is is is going down because I'm getting more more money
in okay it's it's easier third week okay things are coming getting in more maybe
sec maybe fourth week maybe by fourth week maybe I have maybe I have have maybe
like enough to pay for bills I'll be real with you Senpai let's take off the
kayfabe for a second and I'll talk about my previous streaming streaming history
and I will tell you I will tell you some things I will tell you about splits and
stuff okay twitch splits is 50 50 okay 50 50 but it's the easiest and most
accessible thing and the quickest way to get monetized for YouTube monetization
you need you need and we're talking about only the first step of monetization
4,000 watch hours or 1 million short views plus 1000 no I think they changed
it 500 subscribers after that it goes through a manual review okay it takes a
long time as someone who is small and it doesn't help that if your videos even
though you're calculating yes I should have this many this many views to make
the 4,000 YouTube will not sometimes count it
let's see thank you for the $20 a nyanyi mesh it sounds like you need more
I want to work for for it though so I will I will be very truthful I will be
very truthful okay what is culling does that play into culling is when YouTube
believes that the following and subscribers are bots and they start
deleting them YouTube on the other hand I believe YouTube let me look it up first
so I don't give you wrong information
you
what's my revenue share blah blah blah okay shorts shorts are 45%
what's super chat
super chat is 7030
Super Chat is 7030.
Super chats are 7030 meaning YouTube will take 30%.
When I was full time streaming on Twitch, my old fans gave me $200.
I would get only $100 a month.
One time I had a birthday celebration.
I only got $250 in the end.
Now imagine this.
I would say this as a streamer.
If you don't get 500 subs,
you do not get the split.
If you get partner, your split is the same.
Unless you meet a certain threshold of subs, you do not get the split.
If you get money, you get nothing.
Most companies are with YouTube unless they have a deal.
This is public information and my own experience with it.
If you get monetization faster on Twitch, you might not even reach it on YouTube.
You might not be able to get partnership because it's very difficult.
If it's 4,000 watch hours, that's for one year.
It's a milestone to be a YouTube partner and monetize on YouTube.
I'm proud of what VLR has done.
Imagine I have the most seniority in terms of streaming.
In the three years of which I have been streaming as a VTuber, I have never gone monetization or even close to monetization on YouTube.
I did get monetization on Twitch though.
It's even harder to hit partner than to get monetized on YouTube.
Because you need a certain amount of hours streamed and hitting exactly or more than 78 average viewers.
That is a near impossible number or a number and that is not including rates.
You cannot have that number with rates, you cannot have that number with collabs, you cannot have that number with anything else.
Which is why, doesn't 78 average viewers put you on the top 1% of streamers? Wrong.
Senpai, you must know this. Just at 20 viewers, 20 average viewers, you are the top 1% of Twitch already.
For 78 viewers, you are the top 0.01%.
And that's how it is.
And that is what most of the hurdle is for streaming full time.
As for what is the best way to probably support me, Patreon is probably one of the best ways.
And YouTube membership slash YouTube super chats will be the least amount taken.
As well as tips as well, if you want to just donate through stream elements is probably the best.
Merch will be good as well.
So any little support is fine.
But those are the hurdles that prevent a lot of people from streaming full time.
To be honest, I don't know a lot of the networking what's better and what's better.
Because I just kind of stream, right?
And management takes care of all that stuff.
YouTube membership would probably be one of the good ways to support and super chats and Patreon and anything.
And if you can't afford any of that, just watching our streams is just fine as well.
Watching our streams, interacting, drawing fan art, anything to support the company is great.
It worked really hard and which is why hopefully everyone in VLOR can become full time streamers and just to entertain you.
Oh yeah, and clip as well.
If you clip, there's a chance that it will be probably edited by an editor and put into like shorts or a compilation.
You'll literally like comment hitting the bell. That is literally how you do it.
That's literally how you support.
But that is why there's a lot of people who have additional jobs or have something else to supplement the streaming.
Because of those hurdles.
And if I believe what I read about what YouTube gives as they're like how to grow your channel.
We are to believe that comments boost the algorithm for more eyes to be seen.
More subscribers also gives more eyes and a sense of trust as well as boosting your content.
And then likes and then they look at likes to two views.
So for example, if for example, I believe this is the case, I don't know how accurate it is because it's YouTube.
But comment on VOD specifically, it can be anything, it can be anything.
But if YouTube sees that you have tons of views, tons of views, but no likes or very little likes, they're like people hated that.
People hated that so we're not going to push it.
Kind of things like that.
I'm not fully aware of the mysteries of the YouTube algorithm because the real YouTube algorithm is a beast.
And if I knew how to abuse it, everyone would abuse it.
No, seriously, I have no idea how it works.
Same thing with Twitter. If I grew quite a bit on Twitter and I have no idea how I did it, I have no idea how I did it and I'm a little scared because I literally have no idea what I did.
So yeah.
So yeah, everything is really confusing and I don't really know, but I can tell you why there are some hurdles that prevent people from full time streaming is especially the splits, the splits, especially on Twitch.
If you're looking at your kind of like smaller indie Vtuber, that is most likely why they don't stream full time.
But I have no idea. I have no idea. Okay, and any recommendation for a good iPad. Find one that fits you and have a looser elastic because if the elastic pinches against your face, it's going to hurt and leave a little dent.
And you're going to be embarrassed so you never take your iPad off. Make sure the elastic is quite loose on you but still holding on.
Yeah, I had to wear an iPad because I got pink eye once in school and it was too tight and like the next day, the strap was still there.
The strap from the iPad was still there.
Yeah. Not because you were a tunie.
Well, part of it, I thought that looked cool, but also, yeah.
Yeah, I got pink eye once so now, so I know how it is.
So yeah, the pressure of the elastic or in cloth, if it's too tight, can be really painful.
But I think it looks cool.
Okay, next question. I hope that helped with some questions about, what's the word, why some people don't get full time streamer and for me it's that, oh, hold on, I didn't put my theme on.
Is it okay? I forgot to put on my theme. Ah, there we go.
Okay, okay. I forgot my BGM. That was my bad.
My precious Kohai, thank you for being you, Senpai's.
Days are happier when you're in them. I hope you're being as kind to yourself as you are Senpai.
Oops. Oops, that's my bad. This was a compliment that got shifted in. That shifted in. That was my, that was my pad.
Oops, I'm sorry. I'm sorry. But thank you. Thank you, Senpai. I accidentally saved this into the list. That was definitely my bad, but I really appreciated.
I'm kind of hard on myself, Senpai. I'm kind of hard on myself, but I'll do my best to be prouder of myself in my achievements.
Thank you. Very good advice.
This was actually truly an accident that this slipped in. I was trying to save a bunch of advice questions, but I think I accidentally saved this one, but thank you. I really appreciate it.
I'm tired. Come next to me so we can cuddle. Wait, what is this also?
I need to review these questions. I need to review these. Why did some of the ones that are not questions mixed in?
Yes, we can cuddle.
I'm so scared. I'm so scared. What the next one's going to be?
Okay.
My coworker goals on 4chan is insensitive and may or may not have a crush on me. Do I extort him or reject him? Serious answers only.
You take his phone number and you put it in a bathroom stall and then you say, hey, great time here. And then you order 70 pizzas to their location.
Different from different companies and make them fight each other, but also extortion 100%.
I don't think that's legal, Kohai.
What did I write in my thing? All advice are for jokes and giggles and hee hee ha ha. Please do not take them seriously. All advice takers are responsible for their own actions, regardless of what advice has been given. You're welcome.
I don't actually know. To be honest, I don't actually, it's like, wow, you really hate 4chan users. I don't hate 4chan users. I just don't have a great trust in the form.
Are they called forms? I don't use this site, but I do have occasionally my friends, my gal pals and my friends will go on and they'll be like, okay, let's see what people are saying about you.
And I'll leave the nasty icky stuff away. And yeah. So I don't actually go on there. I have my friends. Occasionally, some people might give advice, but I rather not go on there since I'm a sensitive little baby.
But yeah, he's all in shits and giggles, you know? Next.
It's probably like Reddit. And guess what? I don't go on Reddit either, except for, um, what's the word? I don't go on Reddit either, except for like, um, for example, I'm like, oh, how, for like tech advice, how do I make my lights go on?
Does that make sense?
So I look if it's like, so it's either tech people on YouTube or tech people on Reddit. They're very good.
So yeah, that's, um, that's the thing. Okay, I hope this isn't too personal, but when you draw blow bubbles, okay, okay, I haven't blown bubbles in a long time.
Do you watch the bubbles fall to the ground and think about how falling bubbles are like a metaphor for beauty and fragility of life as you said shed a single tear or do you be popping all of them bubbles?
Um, I kind of pop all of them. I pop all the bubbles or I let them let them float off and see where they go. And that's it.
No, seriously, I don't think too much on it because bubbles are just like us. Not a permanent thing in life. You're welcome.
You blow them like, you know, from the bubbles or or you can like wave the wand, the like wand and then it makes bubbles too.
This isn't really a question, is it? It must have gone mixed in. This is not really like, uh, this isn't really like a advice thing.
I slipped in. Oops. I swear I went through them and I guess some stuff slipped in. Don't let me do this when I'm like super tired.
Free Q&A. Okay, let's break kayfabe for a brief second. All right. All right. I've had a kami oh she for two plus years.
Okay, okay. Don't break. Don't break. Don't break. And I'm very dedicated to her. She has got me through some extremely rough times and I owe her a bigger depth than I could, could hope to ever pay back.
Unfortunately, her streaming times barely line up with my work schedule anymore.
Recently, I discovered you. I really enjoy your general vibe and sense of humor.
I appreciate the entire experience and am really drawn to your choice of games. Simply put, I genuinely enjoy you for entirely different reasons and have rarely clicked with a creator so quickly in my four plus years in VTuber rabbit hole.
So my conundrum is this. I know that I'm not portraying my kami oh she by watching and enjoying you but deep down it feels like as though I am.
How do you suggest I resolve this internal struggle without giving up either of you? Apologies that this is too heavy or real of a question.
I hope I loved your take today. I love your take on this. Thank you. Much love.
Ugh, Petrina, what you eating is bad. But, okay, okay, okay.
Ignoring the fact that I want to be the favorite here.
And that it should only be me.
Let me get my friend. Let me get my friend.
Let me get my friend and title.
Oh no, another question.
Another question on this.
Wow, I think you guys are making mercy.
Neat.
I think you are making mercy. Neat.
You snitched on me. Neat.
Last time maybe you shouldn't have been a little bitch.
Anyway, let's talk about Ostees.
Ostees are your number one, your favorite things in idol culture.
But anyways, like all things change. And sometimes you have to accept that.
And as all creatures, we have to accept it as well.
One example, in your life, sometimes, are you always friends with your best friends?
Perhaps over time, your best friend and you will grow my distance on your part.
And that is just a fact of life.
Change is happening in your life.
Things, for example, when chips may die,
and others will begin.
So please do not feel you are completely indebted and into complete loyalty.
Because as your Oshi, your Oshi will also view changes.
And view ish, and also in yourself.
And you too will also view new new Ostees all the time.
And you may move on, and that is just the way of idols.
It is unfortunate, but it is a thing that happens.
For example, if you have a friend or a partner,
and your Oshi may graduate,
and you can keep your Oshi in your heart forever, forever.
But if, for example, you find that your Oshi has pivoted
different genres that you do not, that you do not vibe with,
and perhaps it is time to move on from an Oshi,
and take them for their time that they have spent with you.
But perhaps it is time for both you and them to go on.
Well, I believe that if you believe that you are between your Oshi,
then you can continue to watch your Oshi.
But remember that your Oshi can go through changes,
and that changes sometimes means having to say goodbye.
Now I will bring back Mashi.
Oops, where the heck is my window? There it is.
I hope, yeah, I had time to cool off. I had time to cool off.
I had time to cool off, so now, so now, I hope you got your answered question.
I hope your question got answered.
Yeah, I found a magical cat.
I found a magical cat just the other day, and then we became besties.
I feel like a magical girl.
Okay, here's the next question.
Ugh.
Do your parents know? No, it's a secret, okay? You keep it a secret, right?
Dear Mercy, I need life advice on two things.
One, I'd like to build Gunpla, so for my next project,
should I do two small models or one big model?
And two, what should I have for lunch tomorrow?
If you don't, don't, don't answer, I will starve instead. Love you, SMPI.
Wow.
Okay.
Personally, I feel like doing maybe two smaller models will be easier than doing one big model.
And for lunch, have Gyoza, I guess?
I'm out of food thoughts because Mama, Mama Mercy is making Gyoza.
And I guess you're going to have Gyoza, too.
It's empty, only Gyoza. You don't understand. The smell of the Gyoza is really good.
It's really good, SMPI.
Where do I find Gyoza?
Oh, check any, check any like place.
Oh, what's another alternative name for Gyoza?
You can find it at like Chinese places, too.
Dumplings, right? Or pot stickies.
They're also called pot stickies, or meat dumplings, or just dumplings.
You can probably find them at like a Chinese restaurant.
Or if there's like a specialty Japanese place, you can get like the Gyoza.
Or you can make it.
Also Walmart, and I think like most grocery stores have like some instant one as well.
So yeah, there you go. Thank you, SMPI, for sending it in.
How'd I get a girlfriend and am I a good SMPI? You're already, I'm already your girlfriend, SMPI.
And yes, you are a good SMPI, as long as you're not a troll, or like someone who's pretending to be a SMPI.
You're welcome.
What is the airspeed velocity of an unlaid and swallow? European or African? Or even Asian?
Next question.
What is the minimum of cleaning products that I should use in the shower? Should I keep sticking to three in one shampoo? I will fucking kill you.
First of all, for, I'm assuming if it's a three in one, this is a question for from a male SMPI.
I'm assuming four male SMPIs. I highly recommend body wash one, two shampoo, three conditioner, and a face wash.
In total, you will have four products.
What's one, what's wrong with three in ones? The reason why three in ones do not work is because your scalp skin and your skin skin are completely different.
So if you use your body wash, it may be too harsh on your scalp, or it might be too light on your skin. Simple.
It's very simple, really.
That's three products too many. Then don't take my advice and die. And be disliked by.
About two in ones. I still don't recommend two in ones. I still don't recommend two in ones. If you want, if you want, I will give you some picks, because I helped Papa Mercy pick some products.
It's very cheap. It's very cheap to get, to get shampoo and conditioner. Whatever works for you.
Okay, whatever works for you, whatever your hair issue is, if you get a lot of dandruff, use a dandruff shampoo and use a matching, the matching conditioner with it.
The shampoo strips, the, okay, shampoo strips conditioner brings back the moisture, understood?
Because if you just use shampoo, it will dry out your hair. It will dry out your hair, which is great if you are a very oily person, if you're an oily person, maybe just stripping is all you need.
Second, second is the conditioner. Conditioner, if you find that your hair is too dry or your scalp is beginning to flay, not, I wouldn't recommend putting it on your scalp, but for males, yes, I would probably recommend putting it on your scalp.
If you find your scalp is flaking too much, try a conditioner with it.
Next is a body wash. A body wash will help you strip, strip yourself. Actually, I recommend five products. Sorry. We'll strip a dead skin cell off of dead skin cells and basically sweat and stuff.
It's very cheap. I believe the best soap you can buy is like a dove bar. A dove bar will help with a bit of adding a bit of moisture as well.
But if you're super manly and you can't stand the girly dove stuff, I recommend an Irish spring bar soap.
Second is a face wash because your face is not the same as your skin. Your face has a different type of texture and sensitivity. It has more pores and there's delicate areas around your face and eyes.
So you need a face wash. I recommend, um, I recommend, uh, there was, I found out the body shop was shutting down. I would have recommended you the seaweed wash from, um,
from, from, uh, the body shop, but it's no longer there. So, uh, there's a, give me a second, give me a second. There's another brand that I really like.
I think this is great for men as well because I feel like it is, uh, it is a wash that a strip that makes you less shiny and helps clears out your pores and makes you feel nice and clean.
So the, um, wash was avenue, avenue, avenue, avenue, a wash.
It is a huge little thing is bath and body works a good place. Now, bath and body works, I think, uh, sucks, sucks, except for their sense. Uh, it sucks. Uh, so this one's called, excuse my French, it's going to be terrible.
But, um, avenue, cleanance, cleansing gel. This is great. It's a huge bottle. It will last you forever. You can buy it for like super cheap.
Um, and I recommend a lotion for men. After your shower, put on some lotion. It will make you feel good and it will keep bringing back some moisture into the skin that you have already, um,
gotten rid of. So, uh, simple lotion that most people use will be a Vaseline lotion.
So I use their cocoa, cocoa radiant. Uh, but you can use anything is fine. You can use, uh, like the aloe vera hydration, advanced repair, whatever, just bring back some moisture in your skin.
And that's it. That is Mercy Modisse. How to, uh, how to get bitches. Tea tree shampoo is good. What about Walmart? Walmart is, you can find all these products at Walmart.
Where does the lotion go? Arms, legs, chest, back, if you can reach. You can buy all these products at Walmart. I am not lying to you. Like all these products can be like maybe a dollar.
So the most you might spend is like, if you use my recommendation, it's going to be a little bit more expensive for the face wash. But if you get a regular face wash at whatever is at, uh, at Walmart, then maybe your five products can be $5.
There's no Walmart in Europe. Uh, in that case, go to a, where do they sell skincare in Europe? Pharmacy? I think they might sell them at pharmacy. Hmm.
I feel like, even if you aren't going to get ladies, I feel like you are going to have, you're going to feel very, you're going to feel much better. You're going to feel much better after you take a shower and you're going to feel like, what?
Oh, I feel good. Where does short hair need conditioner? I said you don't have to use conditioner. Um, but if it's your scalp does, if your scalp does have like really bad, um, if you really have like bad dandruff or you're finding yourself like, um, like you might have like
super flakiness or dryness in your hair, uh, try a conditioner. It's, it's, it's, um, it's not needed. I technically don't really use conditioner. I use conditioner sometimes. In fact, I, instead of a shaving cream, instead of a shaving cream, if I shave, I just use conditioner because it softens the hair anyways and it's easy to shave.
You can save your, save money using conditioner as well. I use conditioner and my hair is still dry. Try a different conditioner. I don't know what type you're using.
Okay. And I will like you a lot if you try these because I want my supplies to feel confident and or maybe too much shampoo. Uh, shampoo in your hand should be only like, I think for men only about, well, I can't use that reference because then that doesn't have it.
Um, a dollop, just like, just in the middle of your palm. So that should be enough. I think, um, if you, honestly, it's really easy to save on these type of things. And I feel like for guys, they tend to have less sensitive skin.
And the most problems I think for guys skin, if I can recall, is just oiliness. So it's easy to do like that.
And soapy use instead of body wash soap, soap and body wash will be used intermittently. So for example, a bar soap will be just fine to use as a body soap. So like I said, Irish spring or a dove, I highly recommend dove body bar.
Because it brings some moisture back, but also helps get rid of the, um, the, um, the dead skin, the dead skin and sweat. And long thick hair adult doesn't cut it. Uh, if you have long thick hair, um, a palm full will be fine, a palm full will be fine.
But also for long thick hair, I highly recommend, um, cause, uh, Tressame, the brand Tressame.
Irish spring makes my skin feels waxy. Try a dove bar then. I, I highly recommend the dove bar more than the Irish spring bar.
I use Tressame myself. And I will tell you, um, my hair, I know it doesn't look like this cause my hair is pretty thin at the edges here, like paper thin.
But my hair is actually, uh, really thick. It used to be as thick as barbed wire. And I switched to a clarifying shampoo, um, because it gets pretty oily. And it, it, uh, helped quite a bit.
It used to be as thick as barbed wire. Like it got really bad. So, uh, so, uh, I actually went to a salon and asked the salon, um, my hair person to be like, what the fuck do I do, man? This is torturing me.
Um, they were like, okay, what brand have you been using? And then I was like, okay, I've been using this brand, this brand, and this brand. And they were like, no, that's no good.
And I said, uh, for a direct store brand, try Tressame. And I said, okay. And I said, okay. And so I used, uh, just, I used just the Tressame shampoo. Lately, I've been seeing that my hair has actually gotten dry at the ends.
So, so I used, um, so I ended up using, um, a, what do you call it? I ended up using conditioner. I ended up using a conditioner. That's, I think it's apple cider and apple cider conditioner to help with the oiliness as well.
Um, I use Tressame and then for my oily hair, I also, I also have to blow dry it at the blow dry my hair. It's so long, but it can get really greasy. So the blow dry will also make it dry out a little bit more.
So that's what I use for my hair.
But yeah, experiment with things. If you're fine, listen, if you, if you're fine, if you're fine with using your three in one, fine, just use your three in one. Okay.
It doesn't matter. It doesn't really matter. It's your choice. I don't, I don't force your hand. Well, I do force your hand sometimes, but but really it's your choice.
It's your choice, but if you like cleaner hair, if you want to feel your skin immaculate and stuff, and you want to feel more moisture, I recommend five steps.
I recommend the five steps, shampoo, conditioner, body wash, hair, not fair hair, face wash, lotion, that's it.
I do admit I hate three in ones because I admit I hate three in ones because your scalp, your face, and your body does not have the same chemistry.
Yeah, you can still use it. I just, I'll silently judge you. Next question.
What's the proper way to prepare your cereal? Some believe you should pour cereal into the bowl first. Others believe that pouring milk first is the best method.
Thoughts, please help me. I'm really hungry. Milk first. No, seriously, it's milk first. It's milk first. Milk first so your cereal doesn't get soggy. You can take your time eating it.
Well, if you want it soggy, then put cereal first. But I don't like soggy cereal, so I actually, what I do is I put the milk in first and then I take my Pikachu spoon because it makes me feel like I'm still youthful and still watching cartoons as I eat my cereal.
I put, I like pour, I might even pour sometimes like one spoonful at a time because I don't like how soggy it gets.
Anyways, people always say, why do you take so long? Well, I'm telling you, sometimes they're stuck at the bottom and it gets soggy.
Or you can eat the cereal and then, yeah, you can eat the cereal and then take a sip of milk. Easy.
There you go. Next question. Wow, people are cancelling me just for that. So many people are saying that.
How many days acceptable to be wearing the same underwear? Keep in mind, I don't sweat much.
As long as you want and it doesn't, guess what? Underwear doesn't disintegrate. So you can keep wearing it as long as you can stand it.
If you can smell your balls or your cooch, then maybe it's time to wash.
There you go. What's the longest you've gone, Mercy? It's embarrassing, but I've gone a month without showering.
I was very depressed. I was very depressed at that time. Please tell me you're lying. No.
That was probably the most depressed I've ever, I was ever.
But I ended up, the most I go now is probably a week and that's it. That's actually kind of the norm.
When was your last shower? Three days ago. We're still good.
We're still good. I don't sweat that much either. I don't sweat that much. I think the water's back on, I think. Yeah, we're good.
You're schooling us on showers? I use a lot, okay? I school you on shower because I care about you, Senpai. But even if I don't shower for a week, my skin is still perfect, my hair is still perfect.
I'm just saying, it's still perfect. I'm still perfect.
My hair still looks like I got out of a salon, okay?
Simple. That's because it's stiff. It's not stiff. It's super soft. If you give me pets daily, Senpai, you would understand how soft it is.
Do you know how long it took me? I just told you, my hair used to be barbed wire. My hair used to be barbed wire, and then I just found the perfect thing.
Anyways, next question. Can't decide what should be the name of my cat. My current cat is named Catherine, or just cat for short, and she needs a pal, so I was thinking of adopting a new cat.
You named your cat cat? You named your cat cat? Catherine with a C, sure. We can play Catherine like the game.
You're going to name your cat cat? Kitty? You're going to have cat and kitty. This reminds me of a post I saw about families be naming their kid Rex, but their dog Joseph.
Well, you have tons of names to choose, but if your cat's name is cat, you can try your other cat to be kitty.
No, I'm serious, maybe.
I mean, like if it's already Catherine, kitty is already like Catherine with a C, so I guess kitty is still the same thing.
Name it cat, like cat cat? Okay, that's kind of cute. Actually, that's cute. That's cute, sure.
Kit and cat, what do you think? I think that's fine.
Yeah, kit, kit and cat, right? So it's like, if you say kit cat together, and then they're like, yeah, that's, that's cute, right? I feel like that was a good name. Whoever suggested that? Yeah, let's go with that. You name your next cat kit.
Coffee or green tea? I prefer green tea.
I prefer green tea. I don't like drinking coffee. I think it tastes, doesn't taste great. It's too bitter, but I like green tea. Coffee! Any tea tonight? Oh, yeah, I did. Oh, shoot, I don't remember what tea I made, though.
I don't like the taste of, I don't like the taste of coffee, unless it's like extra sweet, and it can barely be called coffee. Like, I guess.
No, wait, hold on, let me sniff it. It's apple cinnamon again. The tea I have is apple cinnamon again.
Why are we at an English word of the day? Conundrum. Conundrum. Why the conundrum?
So, for example, the most coffee, I think, I think most empires figured out, figured out that I'm Canadian. Okay, so the only other coffee I like is an ice cap from Tim Hortons.
Yep, sorry.
So, yeah, I don't like coffee. I don't like coffee.
I think most empires figured it out really, really easily. Why are all VTubers Canadian? I don't know. I don't know. Like, literally, I don't know.
I don't know. I just wanted to be here and with my senpais, and I'm going to just guess everyone else stole my idea.
That's it. Yeah. So, it doesn't really matter. I think everyone else just stole my idea.
Tea is, I like tea better. I will drink nothing but tea. I don't put anything in my tea. I think the flavor is fine as it is.
The apple cinnamon tea? I didn't get it from Tim Hortons. I have it from a brand called Stash.
Does that mean we get Tim Hortons once a month too? Everyone fights for the Timbits? I'm kind of allergic too, so.
Snash? No, it's Stash. Stash, S-T-A-S-H.
Hi, since you're Canadian, what's your Tim's order? Ice cap with a whole wheat bagel and cream cheese.
Sometimes, if I'm feeling a little frisky, I'll ask for a Boston cream.
Actually, Tim Hortons donuts are the only donuts I can eat. I can eat their yeast donuts because they don't contain eggs.
But if they're cake donuts, if they have cake donuts, I cannot eat them. Which is why I can't have Timbits because all the Timbits are made together.
So the Timbits are kind of all mixed in, so I can't have Timbits.
Intaminated with eggs? Yeah. There's a high chance that I always ask for the ones that are the furthest from touching other donuts.
If there's a donut that's touching another one, I try to avoid that donut.
So sometimes I'll get like a maple cream one instead of Boston cream if the Boston cream is too close to the cake donuts.
Or I ask them to use a different tong.
I like Poutine. I do like Poutine. And small amounts. I'm not like a huge Poutine person.
So yeah.
I like Poutine. I do.
Next question. How can I be more confident around others?
Develop your ego so far beyond people that nothing can faze you.
What's Poutine? It is a Canadian specialty. It is essentially fries or chips in other countries.
I like the UK or Australia, we call them chips, with cheese curds and gravy. It is kind of like street food.
Yes, remember my story as well. But essentially, how do you become confident around others?
It's a thing to work on. It's a thing to work on. I can tell you my confidence got smushed to heck.
But when I was a very confident girl, I just always told myself that I was the best.
I was the best. People will love me. If they don't love me, they're weird.
And then I got my ass kicked. By ass kicked, I mean like I got Meadow Illinois.
Sounds like a mess. You don't eat it with your hands. You eat it with like a fork.
I like regular fries for Poutine. You are the best though. I still wish I had that confidence I had back then.
I lost it because of some stuff. I am a really shy person. I have trouble talking with others. I haven't made any new friends in a year.
Would you have any advice on how I can? I feel like my senpais have very similar problems.
I feel like my senpais have very similar problems.
Okay, this is going to sound bad. But the best way to talk to someone and to be a good listener is to act.
This is stealing from a book. This is stealing from a book called How to Win Friends and Influence People.
Listen carefully to what people say. Respond to what they say. Oh, to interest in what they're talking about.
And do stuff. Try on error. This is going to take a lot of confidence.
But next time you go out to an event, look to the next person next to you and be like, hi, my name is Blank. Nice to meet you.
I'm really looking forward to whatever event you're at.
It's going to be a lot of work. Our submission is closed. I have quite a few to go through as well.
Honestly, if you can make friends online, you can make friends in real life.
I actually have trouble making friends online than I can in real life, I guess.
The first step is hardest. If you go to a convention, if you want to talk to someone and maybe you don't have a topic to talk about,
be like, hey, I don't know if you're at a convention.
Hey, I noticed you have this on your phone. Do you like this character?
And if it's just a simple thing, if they don't seem like they want to talk to you, just be like, oh, okay, well, I have something to do now.
At your round sometime. Bye. Get out of there.
Get out of there.
Get out of there. But if you are interested in meeting people, show genuine interest in the other person.
Don't just be like, me, me, me, me, so show genuine interest in the other person and be like, oh yeah, I'd like, oh yeah, let's chat more.
Oh my gosh. Hope to see you again soon. And if you want, you can be like, oh yeah, do you have like a discord?
But don't be like, don't be. Last time I went to a convention, don't be the guy who's like, where do you live?
What hotel are you staying at? Where are you going to eat tonight? What's your room number? Okay.
That is, don't be like that. Don't be like that.
So don't be like that because you're unlikely to get like, oh, do you use discord? I'd love to keep in contact.
Okay. Our coal high gets hit on a lot. It's the way I dressed.
How do you dress like this? Like this, duh.
Or I, or honestly, I just like, any upcoming cons? No, I'm not a con person anymore. I've become, what do you call it?
I've become, do you have a VLR sensor? IRL? Yeah, yeah, I do.
Um, yeah, I just walk around with this, with this giant pair of scissors in my hair and the VLR logo. That's how I look.
I become a Shedden. Yeah, a recluse, a Shedden. So I don't go to cons. I don't feel comfortable with going to cons.
And I am now having the new worry if, even if I'm like, even if I do go to a con, there is no percentage higher chance, a percentage of a higher chance.
And I'll be recognized just by my voice alone.
No, I'm serious. That's something that I'm actually scared of.
Because my entire life has been, has been, has been, oh my gosh, I found you at this convention or I found you at this place because I heard you laugh.
Or, oh my gosh, I found you because I heard you, you, your voice.
So, um, and the thing is I'm a giggler. I'm a laffer. I'll, I just laugh.
And, uh, I laugh a lot. So it's too noticeable.
Yeah, I, I, I am, was, I'm not good with people in real life anymore. Honestly, I'm not good with real people anymore.
I may be an extrovert. So I'm just like, huh. So I, I had a nightmare, like a couple of nights ago, I was like, I was at a con.
And then I, I was like, oh, that's so cute. Like a, like a, at a booth. And then someone turned around and was like, Mercy, Moe, Deast.
And I go, and I woke up.
See, the thing is that it wouldn't be much of a problem, but I am a traditionalist and I don't want people knowing me.
You know, I don't want people knowing me. I don't like, I don't like it when people figure it out.
And I definitely, definitely, definitely don't get me wrong.
I trust Senpai's, a lot of my Senpai's, but there are a lot of people with malicious intent. So for example, um, if someone find out, find out who I am, maybe they'll take a picture of me from a distance and then post it all over online.
And then I get mean comments and then I'm crying and then, you know,
or if, you know, it could be even worse. Like for example, they might follow me home and I still have my parents to think about, you know.
And like, you know, yeah.
If, if there is a chance, if there is an off chance, if there is an off chance that perhaps we do meet IRL by accident or a coincidence, I ask my Senpai's to keep it to themselves.
Keep it to themselves as our little, little secret.
Okay, what about a very handsome man? If I met a very handsome man, um, I still don't trust it.
I've had the re, okay, I'll be real with my Senpai's for a second.
The reason why I have trust issues and the reason why I have mental Illinois is because I used to have a friend who I thought was my friend, but they were really, they tried to ruin my life.
And I didn't know, but the entire time they were like talking behind my back and stuff. So I cannot trust anyone now.
So I cannot trust anyone. Which is why, um, which is why I have trouble trusting if, even if you do have the, the sweetest intent.
Did you write a tweet longer? No, I had the tweet longer written about me.
And I did not do anything. It wasn't a tweet longer. It was like a Facebook thing, which is why I quit Facebook too.
Um, no, I think they were just using me as like a scapegoat.
I think they were using me as a scapegoat.
Because, um, they, they spread a lot of lies about me. And then I got like constantly harassed.
So which is why, um, I tend to, tend to keep things to myself. Okay, sometimes.
So yeah, I tried to keep things to myself. So, uh, when, when the whole thing happened, I was, I was like in the middle of exams.
So I didn't know it was happening until like when I went outside to a convention, someone spit on me and like called me names.
And I didn't know what was happening until that happened. And then I was like, hated. And then it took years, but people found out that that person was spreading lies.
So yeah, I have trust issues. So even if like someone who's super, super, super nice comes up to me, I cannot.
I cannot trust them.
It took years for me to like open up again.
It took me years to open up again, which is why I have a bit of trust issues. And which is why I do have very close friends, but never, you know, I do have very close friends, but I don't make more friends than that.
I have my Ryder die friends and not more, much more than that.
That's it. And my Ryder die friends are my gen mates, some, some IRL friends.
And, and of course,
Serenity.
And of course, some other friends, online friends.
Yeah.
So yeah, that's why I'm just like, keep it a secret, but also I won't trust you.
And that's why I don't trust you and you always stay in that cage.
Next question.
Should I get this limited edition skin for a gacha character or feed myself for three days, feed yourself for three days, because if you're looking at a different character and with lustful eyes, and it's not me, I'm going to be very jealous.
Okay, next question.
No, no, why are you saying get the skin? No, no, no.
You're going to look at the skin with lustful, lustful gaze and I'm right there.
No, no, no, no, the game you're playing is free to play. Use your, use your free currency. Don't use real cash.
Don't use real cash.
No, no, it's free to play. It's free to play.
It's free to play.
Do your dailies.
But it's a limited skin. Well, maybe you should have just saved up for the limited skin.
Huh?
Oh my gosh.
Get the food.
The limited skins are only pay to win. You can admire it in a distance. That's fine.
I'd rather, I'd rather eat my own foot than pay for, pay for a gacha game.
And I've already gotten, gotten everyone I wanted in like, Nikkei.
Get your food stocks, I guess. Yeah, you can get the skin.
Ah.
Thank you Anonymous for 20. The limited skin.
It's Yukohai.
Is she? It's me? It's me?
Oh, thank you.
Thank you Anonymous.
The rest, the other senpais are telling you to buy the skin, so I guess you have to buy the skin.
Unfortunately, I think that paying for a free to play game is absurd.
My question for you is how can I stop loving you so much, Kohai? Keep loving me.
You can't stop.
Next question.
A friend of mine got me with a trick. What is the sound of one hand plapping?
I still don't get it. Anyways, should I keep his car or get back to him?
Show him your moves. Show him your moves.
Clap with one hand.
I can't, I can't clap with one hand though, but if you, with enough practice, you can make a whole applause.
Do you get crowns limited skin? No, and I didn't care for crowns limited skin.
Read again. Clapping.
What's the difference between that? I thought that was just a spelling error.
I thought that was a spelling error. I thought they made one hand clapping.
You don't think so?
I have no idea what this means then.
I thought it was a type ball.
I have no idea what this means then. What does this mean? Is this like a pull your finger thing?
Yeah, pull my finger.
I got it back in him.
Part on their pillow.
Leaf.
Anyways, I don't know what this means, but if it's enough to key the car,
well, I don't think that's enough. Keying your car is not enough.
It's not enough.
Okay, man, giving them the sugar-free, high-rebowl gummy bears as a gift.
You're welcome.
Mercy, I love being caged with you.
What does it say about my psyche? You're perfectly normal. Of course you want to stay.
Next question.
Hi, Mercy. I really enjoyed your streams, and I hope you get some good rest after your busy debut week.
I did have a question for your Q&A stream. I'm going to be writing an MCAT exam in a few months.
I know my call high was quite the student, so I was wondering if you had any tips for stepping to share a surprise.
Thanks, love you, Mercy.
Hmm, oops.
Next, over some stuff.
I just read my textbook out loud.
I read it out loud and I wrote some facts that I was like, oh, interesting, nice.
That's all I really did.
Sometimes if I really memorized something, I would read it out loud and write it on down as well, like rewrite the whole thing.
Just so it can be in my mind.
Take some breaks.
Why did you major in Mercy?
Well, a lot of things.
I rewrote and read out loud, so for example, if I grab what I have, I don't have a textbook.
Oh wait, I do have a textbook.
Sort of.
For here, I can have like, oh, shit.
Here, vocabulary where it's often used in the Japanese language proficiency test are divided into various themes organized into chapters and sections for ease of study.
You may progress equitably through each chapter or begin wherever at whatever chapter interests you.
Things like that. If you read it out loud, it works.
It works, generally.
What really helps me when I was studying was definitely reading it out loud, but also taking an actual interest in the subject.
So if I was reading something and I didn't like the subject or I thought the subject was boring, I didn't.
I didn't. I would force myself to be super interested in the subject.
I'd be forcing myself super interested hyperfixate on it.
Which is why. Oh my gosh.
Ring! Ring cloud! Hi!
I forced an interest. I don't know. Are you studying in a field that you want?
Most of the subjects I studied and I picked specific classes that...
What was the class you really enjoyed?
Oh!
The class I really enjoyed was...
What was it called?
Early communications... Early communication history.
A subject that one that I had no interest in? Calculus.
Calculus. I didn't give a shit about calculus.
I nearly failed calculus.
I hate math. I hate math.
It doesn't help that the professor, when I went up to the professor, when I was like, okay, I'm confused about this.
What do I do? How can you explain this to me? The professor was like, ask your peers.
And I went to ask my peers and they went, I don't know.
Great. Great. Great.
Fuck you.
That's probably another thing why I didn't like math at all.
And I'll tell you, when I was in elementary school, or grade school, I had, I loved math.
I loved math.
When I got to like middle school, high school, whatever you call those grades,
I was getting punished for getting the right answer right.
So for example, I would write, for example, I didn't put something in brackets, I got a zero in it.
Why would I put something in brackets if it doesn't require being in brackets?
For example, two times two. Why would I put that in brackets?
No, but because I didn't put it in brackets, I got a zero on it.
Another time, it equals, you know, like, or if you equal, and then there was a time where they made me write out my answers,
not like write out my answers like, oh, equals, so and so, like with the equals sign and the number,
they would write, they would make me write my process, they would make me write my process.
So I literally wrote, I added so and so and did it to this number.
And therefore, this question is this.
And this happened for many, many, many years.
And so I freaking hated math.
No, but like, it's not like show your work, like, oh, here's my like order of things.
It was, you had to physically write out what you did.
Like, literally, write out what you did, like, I added, I a space a d d d e d.
These numbers to do that.
And I said, and then you had to write down, like, the whole thing.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, like, I added three, two, four and equals seven for like that.
And that went on for years.
And which is why I hate math.
Which is why I hate math.
And then I was, I, my mama, mama, Mercy used to be a math teacher.
She used to be a math teacher.
Okay.
So when I gave her my math homework to look over, she said it was fucking ridiculous.
She helped me, but she thought it was stupid because she looked over my test and she was like, why were you docked marks for not putting like, for example, if it's nine, if the answer is nine, right.
And the question does not call for to the first decimal decimal.
I was still being punished for like writing nine instead of 9.0.
Or if it was rounded to the next number and I would round it to the next number, I still got punished because for some reason I wasn't supposed to round it.
So my mom, my mom, mama, mama, Mercy understood why I hated math because she thought it was ridiculous.
She in fact went to the teacher and the teacher was like, well, that's how we do it here.
And mama was like, pissed.
She was pissed.
Mama was pissed.
So it didn't help.
And honestly, a lot of teachers did that to me.
So mama was pissed and like usually mama literally mama mama went, I used to be a math teacher.
And these questions are answered correctly because of this, this, this, and they're like, that's not how we do it in our curriculum.
So mama was like, if this is going to be like this, do not take math.
Avoid math.
Like mama was literally like, do not take math if this is how they're going to, going to do it.
But yeah, like, no, I ended up, I ended up, I think calculus, I ended up dropping, I ended up dropping because I was kind of ridiculous of how bad it was.
Yeah.
Anyways, that's how you become, you pass the MCAT and become a doctor.
I don't know what it goes with.
But if you read things out loud, if you do practice questions, if you do, if you do, was that uni math class?
Uni math class was the professor that was like, well ask your peers and I asked my peers and they're like, I don't fucking know.
It was like kind of like when I was still like grades one through whatever numbers in your country was when I hated math and that's where mama helped me the most.
All of my, all of my, all of my, all of my classes that kind of involved math were not great because probably because of my hate for them.
I ended up not doing very well in anything that did math.
So good luck Senpai.
Good luck on your MCAT.
Become a doctor.
Make lots of money.
Save people's lives.
A communication history was awesome.
Yeah.
Anything was theory with theory I excelled at.
So even if it's complex theory, I really loved.
I like complex theory and is not game theory, shut up.
For example, I like looking at theories and how history and how history works and basically formulating meanings into things.
Those things were really, really fun to me.
Like really, really fun to me.
So like if I had kind of like anything to do with like how if we talked about basically like how people perceive things and how things are and like theories relating to that.
That was great fun for me.
So that was really a lot of fun and I can use that in everyday life too when I'm thinking about things.
Yeah, did I take philosophy?
No, but I took a lot of a lot of things, theory things and I a lot of times I would get it before my peers, my like classmates.
And so I would explain to my classmates and then with examples and stuff and they were like, oh, I get it now. Thanks.
But I managed to pick things up like theory right away.
Honestly, another course that I had lots of great fun in was law.
Law was really fun too.
I got an A plus in that course. It was really fun.
And the professor gave me like out of nowhere, he just gave me a grant.
He gave me a grant and I was like, oh, thank you.
It paid a good chunk of my tuition.
Yeah, it was really fun. It was really fun.
Professor asked me if I wanted to be a lawyer and I was like, I have to take math to become a lawyer.
Was that the one that told you to take acid? No.
Actually, the one that told me to take acid was the early communications history professor. That was really fun.
I would tell you, honestly, I would tell you more about my academic background.
But I think my, I think a lot of people would, would, um, would, I think a lot of people would, uh,
start to question exactly why, why I'm doing this line of work instead.
I think many people would question why I'm doing this line of work instead.
Oh, it's not like doxing myself. It's more like, I'd rather, I'd rather not tell
since a lot of people might judge by it. Just, just know, just know that maybe I'm a little overqualified.
That's it. But I don't really want to say because then people might start making theories and stuff.
Okay, what is the easiest way to get a girl to fall in love with you?
Unironically, be nice.
Now, be nice. Like, if you are a considerate person, um, if you are considerate, if you think of others,
uh, if you, like, for example, um, offer, offer your like umbrella or you like a coat if like a girl is like warm, she will notice that and she will remember that.
Shut the fuck up. No, don't be one of those nice, no, I'm literally mean, don't, like, you, you have to be genuine in your niceness though.
You have to be genuine in your niceness.
The bars and health, yeah, it's pretty, it's pretty, it's pretty low. Wouldn't they abuse that? Like, who is they? Who is they? Are you cheating on me? Are they?
Just be nice. Just be nice.
Like, if you say you're a nice guy and everyone around you said you're a big frickin' jerk, maybe you're not a nice guy.
Be a good person.
Literally, okay, fine, fine, fine. We'll change out semantics. We'll change semantics around, okay? Be a good person and you'll be noticed.
Hold, hold doors open for someone. Check on someone if they're, they're okay.
Help, help your mom with your growth, with her groceries.
But what if I'm a bad boy? Some girls will like that, but I feel like most girls, or at least the girls that I know, genuinely prefer a good person.
Like, for example, if you, if you, like, don't be, don't be weird.
Don't be weird. Don't be like, oh, I bought this girl flowers and she wouldn't, she wouldn't give me a kiss goodnight.
Okay.
Instead, just be like, oh, I gave her flowers and she seemed to really like it and that's all I need, you know?
Not even a peck. I mean, like, it depends on the relationship. If you don't know her very well, or you don't have that type of relationship with her, then yeah.
Anyways, that doesn't apply to me though. Clearly, if I just kidnap my senpais, you'll fall in love with me, right? Easy.
What if she loves another guy? Move on. Move on. It's over. That moment, over. Move on.
Move on. It's over. I'm sorry. That's it. Next question.
Okay, help. I found this new Vtuber company that's full of cute. I don't know if that is girls. How can I save myself from their deadly grasp before it is too late? It's too late already. You have already fallen and you've been already groomed.
Okay, next question.
I need advice on how to get more beautiful Mercy laughter in my life. Make a clip compilation and play it over and over again.
How can I overcome my fear of job interviews? I have to earn money for us, you and me. I can't do it now if I'm too anxious to even go to a job interview.
Practice. Practice with your friends.
Practice with your friends. Practice in a mirror. Practice. Practice, practice, practice. Get your mom to sit down, ask you some interview questions, and then memorize them.
Force yourself. I don't like driving, but I drive a lot. So, as you just got to do it.
Sorry. Sorry, you just have to do it. Practice. If you go to a bunch of job interviews, it gets easier, trust me.
Next question. I've never been in a relationship before. How do you suggest I get a girlfriend? I'm already your girlfriend.
But remember Nyan Taddle.
I don't know how to approach women. Can you help?
Just talk to them? I think I've answered this one already. So, we'll move on.
Oh my gosh. Why do you guys always make these long morals? At least for Q&A.
Mercy, will you go out with me? I'm going out with every single senpai already.
We're all in a relationship. A loving relationship. I'm in a loving relationship with my senpais.
Mercy, I need some serious advice. How can I prove my love to you? If I prove it, will I be allowed out of the cage? I promise I won't ever leave. Please believe me.
Sounds like I can't believe you. Stay in the cage.
Hi, Mercy. I'm looking forward to giving up my agency and spending the rest of my days only looking at you.
Normally, I'd be a good senpai and just figure it out, but I heard you were offering life advice.
There are some fun ways to break it to my work that I will no longer be coming to the office and may not have internet access or a computer.
I don't know. I guess you have to leave your two weeks notice.
It's like, ah, personal agency.
I guess you leave your two weeks notice. I don't know how to say that. Just leave your two weeks notice and go peace.
Oh, but yeah, the cage has internet though. I let you, you have supervised, um, supervised internet.
For Q&A, I'm too lazy to do laundry, but also hate being perceived. Any tips on how to not do laundry while also being clothed enough to go outside without drawing gaps, gigs?
Goof? I don't know what that last word means. Um, wear clothes.
Wear clothes. You can re-wear your clothes.
Anyways, re-wear your clothes. Spray on some febrize or like some perfume. You're good to go by.
Ah, re-wear your clothes. Done.
We're live at Vice stream and feel free to respond serious or silly or not at all. I wouldn't, I won't mind just sharing some thoughts.
How do you think people bond? Or how do you build a stronger community where people want to be there doing things together?
Maybe you have some observation from VTubing. I don't ever plan to get together because every time I've tried, people haven't been interested.
And it's used to be less of a problem because I was involved in established friend groups and communities where I was invited.
But after college, especially COVID, I stopped receiving invitations. I feel like I don't know how to bootstrap group plans on my own.
I have parallel struggles at work getting more into leadership and struggling to motivate co-workers to engage.
I'm not sure if I'm the problem or if I'm surrounded by the wrong people. I think I'm probably well-liked as a side character but never people's inner circles.
I don't know what others do that I'm not doing. Thanks.
Okay.
This one might come off as a controversial answer. But you have to know your crowd.
You kind of have to know your crowd. So I have different friend groups and they all like different things. You cannot force the same things amongst them.
First of all, you're not a secondary character. You are someone important.
But don't forget you are also maybe perhaps yourself have been sealing yourself off due to COVID or what else did you say?
Or you're falling out with friends. Perhaps you've already put a shield amongst yourself.
But remember that you're each group of people if in order to engage and stuff they have their own interests and needs as well.
So for example, your co-workers maybe what is motivating them is different from what your friends are.
So for example, if you are in a leadership role and you're like everybody let's do an icebreaker perhaps it feels forced.
Perhaps it feels forced and people feel like they're obligated to do it.
Instead of something that you want to cultivate friendships with.
But if you're in a leadership position, you have to know that everyone will view you as the leader, the boss and someone who either you listen to and they will not want to engage in like a friendship type of thing.
I don't think workplaces are a great place to make friends simply because there's that power dynamic that people feel around you.
As well as well with your friend groups and other friend groups, you really have to get to know what they're into.
So if you're going to suggest something like, oh, hey, let's do a movie together, you have to be have to gauge what kind of movie they're into.
For example, I have a group of friends who loves watching anime, but the other group of friends does not like watching anime.
And therefore they would prefer to watch something such as old retro classic movies.
Like the birds. Let's just pick the birds as an example.
Or like even Shrek, exactly, like maybe your friend group, that friend group prefer friends or something.
At the same time, understand that there's a dynamic within friend groups that might be a little different than what you're into.
Instead of trying to be the people pleaser and the event organizer for your friends, I highly recommend making events with only perhaps one friend or two friends amongst your peers.
Don't try to force people together who don't want to be together.
So maybe they're cool with just hanging out and talking in like a group group chat, but they're not okay with hanging out in a call.
So in that case, I would say lower your friendship group to about one or two people that you can truly hang out with at any time.
How you pick those people is entirely based off how you connect with them.
Remember, if you are in a place of leadership at your workplace, your co-workers may not be the best people to force into or motivate into engaging with things because to them it is an additional chore.
Meanwhile, in another group, if you have a bigger group of friends or if you're new to their environment and you're kind of still in the initiation, we're still getting to know you do not force it.
Do not force it. You will simply make yourself feel like you are too gogetty or you're too strong-handed in your suggestions for events.
So instead, don't try to force things. Make them as suggestions instead.
That's how you deal with people. Don't forget, you are not the side character. People do care about you.
People do care about you. You are someone that someone cares about. But remember, you have to take care of yourself first.
You have to take care of yourself first. Then organize events for people because if you are making events for people to like you, that is not the way to go.
That is not the way to go.
If you are making events because you are close friends with these friends, okay. Ask first. Ask. Hey, do you guys want to do this?
And see if you can, see if you're, you can gage if they're saying yes out of politeness or yes out of like genuine interest.
Okay. Bam.
I hope that was okay advice.
Next question.
Hi, Mercy. The city I live in just announced that there will be no water tomorrow for maintenance.
I'm already filling water in buckets, cups and whatnot. My question is what's the best container to put water in? Sorry for the really dumb question.
A carafe.
I would say carafe.
You can just use a carafe for drinking water.
If you're looking for water for like watering the garden or something, I suggest a rain barrel.
A what? A carafe. Do you not know what a carafe is?
Okay, it's about like carafe.
Okay.
A carafe.
C-A-R-A-F-E.
It is a container used to serve liquid.
C-A-R-A.
F-E-C-A-R-A.
F-E-C-A-R-A-F-E.
It is not carafe. It is a carafe.
Like giraffe, but a carafe.
Drinking water is great in a carafe.
Especially if it has a lid on it.
Anyways, yeah.
I would use it in carafe.
Store things in the carafe and stuff.
That's it.
I have a few of them because it keeps water cooler and you can also put juice and stuff.
But my, I also have, there's one called a, there's a carafe that you can put on your bedside table.
So it's, it's like the cup is functions at the lid and you can just use it to like drink water as in bed, essentially.
Done.
So yeah, you can get them pretty much anywhere.
That's up for hand washing and non-water stuff. Yeah.
But for drinking water, I suggest using a few boil things, if you boil it.
A carafe can be like hot water safe, but be careful because it is glass.
So let the boiled water cool down to maybe room temperature or even, or even colder, colder than that.
Cooler than that. And then you can just pour it into the carafe.
How big are carafs? It really depends on what carafe you have.
For example, I have a carafe that is like two liters.
So they aren't really uniform at all, but they're really good.
I have a few of them.
I have a few of them at my house and Papa always fills them up when he's bored.
So there's lots of drinking water.
You're welcome.
I don't know how much, excuse me.
I don't know how much that is in Freedom Units. I'm sorry.
That's why I'm just like, oh, okay, well, that's, uh...
No, seriously, I have no idea how much this is in Freedom Units, but I have like a few of them.
Next question.
Oh no, my stomach is growling. I hope you guys can't hear that.
So I recently hung out with this girl and she brought a friend along.
The girls got a little silly and jokingly called me their dog.
They even put a collar around my neck and asked me to bark for them.
They were super excited and I found myself too polite to decline.
And they rewarded me with head baths and doggy kisses, which felt kind of weird.
Any advice for handling similar situations in the future?
What advice do you need? You are now a dog. Mark?
Like, do you hate it or what?
I feel like this is, this is like a lot of people's dreams, right?
Anyways, arf, arf, arf, start barking!
Okay.
Hi, where are you going?
I don't know how you're getting out to meet other girls, so clearly this person isn't a senpai, so I don't give a shit.
Okay?
Okay.
Dear Mercy, I came here to tell you about my problem, helping to make it more problematic.
My issue is that I can't read the atmosphere around me.
I am socially inept and quite naive all the time, especially when it comes to people.
Especially when it comes to problematic situations, or just talking to people.
I'm gonna tell you, it's always gonna be worse.
Live and learn! Live and learn!
Honestly, I have trouble telling apart situations and stuff too, so.
I've only learned with experience.
I think that's called masking.
Mask up!
So mask up!
And start pretending!
You're welcome!
Life advice, hypothetically, if someone were trying to get a decent chunk, going through a decent chunk of anime, let's just say two seasons and two movies, would you have any tips on how to sleep less and anime more?
I don't know about you, but I have...
I have hyper fixation, like super hyper fixation, so I won't stop until I finish.
So I don't know about you, Senpai.
I suppose it's okay if you do it at like 1.5 speed, yeah.
Like, what anime?
Ah, clearly, it's Cardcaptor Sakura!
But hyper fixation, I have a hyper fixation, so I just watch it.
I just watch the whole thing, because I'm really into it.
Oh yeah, you're welcome!
1.5 isn't bad, as long as you get the plot and everything.
Two times speed if you're watching pause.
So yeah, if I hyper fixate on something, for example, I have to literally stop myself from playing games all the way, so...
Yeah, I recommend...
Maybe doing 1.5 speed if you want to do that, if you want to...
If you want to watch it in all its entirety, in the original format, it's in.
I like it, just like it, and you won't sleep.
I haven't heard Tenchi Murio in a long time, I used to read that, read the mango.
But yeah, that is all the question I have, and I went through Senpai 44 questions.
I went through 44 questions, and I kept on getting some in the middle of stream, so I can...
I can see all of this.
Oh, I got so many questions during streams.
I'll see if I can pick one from what I've gotten in case someone wants something.
Okay...
What is my ideal order at McDonald's?
Quarter pounder without cheese.
A quarter pounder without cheese combo.
Nesty and large fries.
Dad.
Nothing.
Going to college starting this fall, any advice from Kohai on time management and relationships once I start the school year?
Your time management is based off of your time's table, not like your schedule.
And your relationships, I recommend setting up specific days where you can hang out with your friends.
For example, I think...
I had a short day on Fridays, and so I hung out with my friends on Fridays after school, yeah.
No cheese? Oh, I don't like cheese on my burger.
Didn't say Nuggies.
I'm not a huge fan of the Nuggies. They don't taste good without the sauce.
Are you a fan of McClurry? Oh, I think they're okay, but I don't indulge in them all the time.
Um, let's see...
I'm getting too perished social to VTubers. Should I turn it down with watching, just step back or stay as I am?
I'm afraid of heartbreak.
I don't know how to answer that to you because the...
Senpai, I want you to be with me all the time, but if it's not good for your health, step back.
I honestly don't like McDonald's chicken nuggets.
So I don't know how Americans can eat it, because it tastes like rubber.
Um, is it because you don't like ice cream too often, or because McDonald's ice creams are broken all the time?
Um, I guess they're all broken all the time, but they're kind of expensive.
They're kind of expensive.
No! It tastes better in Canada. It tastes like chicken, so I don't know what's up with Americans.
But I don't like... Sometimes I just... I don't want to eat something with sauce, right?
So if the chicken nuggets can't taste good without sauce, then I don't really like it.
I guess...
I actually prefer Burger King over McDonald's in terms of like chicken nuggets.
I think their nuggets are better. Their breading is better.
But, um, yeah, McDonald's is really expensive. What about Wendy's?
According to someone who works at Wendy's, I cannot eat Wendy's due to my allergy.
So if I had to order at McDonald's, since there's a lot of McDonald's around,
and it's very convenient, I will get myself a quarter pounder or a double hamburger. No cheese.
Speaking of BK Nuggets, spicy or regular? I kind of like the spicy one.
What about at Tim Hortons Coal High? Um, like I said, if I go to Tim Hortons, I would order a multi-grain bagel with cream cheese.
Or just butter, depending on how I feel.
I think that's fine, but I just don't like cheese on my burgers.
Let's see...
Any advice for moving out?
I am trying to be more independent. Any recommendations for searching for a new cage or saving money?
If you can't answer, a simple good luck would be nice. Good luck!
I, uh, haven't ever moved out. I still love all my parents.
Sorry, Senpai, but good luck to you!
Let's see...
Some of these questions are going to be too long to answer.
Okay, sorry, Senpai, some of these questions are very long, and we've already been here for about, for over three hours now.
We've been here for over three hours now, so I think, um, I think that should be it for questions.
Unfortunately, a lot of the questions I got in are a little bit more intimate.
And I probably wouldn't be able to answer them in a good amount of time.
But my stomach is growling, Senpai.
Like, my stomach is growling, and I'm very hungry.
I'm very hungry, so I'm just going to have to say goodbye for now.
So, I hope Senpai has a great time.
Oh, somebody sent me a question again. I'm sorry if it's the long question. I don't think I can answer.
Okay, maybe I can answer this one.
What is a good relationship for us viewers to have with you?
A loving one!
And it says, uh, if you're willing to break kayfabe again.
A loving relationship, but please do not become overly attached.
That is the end.
Anyway, thanks Senpai for joining me.
I hope you have a good one. I hope some of these advice helps you or ruins your life. I don't really know.
So, I'll see you tomorrow's my day off, so I won't see you tomorrow.
I'll see you Wednesday. Wednesday!
No, no, no, no. It's a normal day.
Wednesday, I'm playing amori.
Thursday, I am streaming quite early because of a collab.
Because of a collab, so please remember the time is different.
Check the calendar. Check the waiting room that I put up.
So make sure you can catch it. If you can't catch it, please catch a lot of it.
I'm sure you have a great time.
Okay, anyways, goodbye Senpai!
I love you!
Screen for Mercy!
Thanks for watching!